AN ATTEMPT TO GET THE ELECTION
OVERTURNED.
IT ENDED ON THURSDAY.
LAKE SAYS SHE WILL APPEAL.
>>> AND THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE THAT INVESTIGATED THE
JANUARY 6th INSURRECTION HAS
RELEASED ANOTHER BATCH OF MORE
THAN 40 WITNESS INTERVIEW
TRANSCRIPTS.
ONE INDICATES WHITE HOUSE
STAFFERS DRAFTED A PRESS RELEASE
AFTER THEN ATTORNEY GENERAL BILL
BARR PUBLICLY REFUTED PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S CLAIMS THAT THE ELECTION
WAS RIGGED.
IT ENDED WITH ANYBODY WHO THINKS
THERE WASN'T MASSIVE FRAUD IN
2020 SHOULD BE FIRED.
THE STATEMENT, THOUGH, WAS NEVER
RELEASED AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL WAS NOT FIRED.
IN ANOTHER TRANSCRIPT, FORMER
TRUMP LAWYER SIDNEY POWELL SAID
THE NUMBERS WE SAW ON ELECTION
NIGHT SIMPLY DIDN'T JIBE WITH
COMMON SENSE.
MATH GENIUSES TOLD HER BIDEN'S
VICTORY WAS STICKILY IMPOSSIBLE.
TRUMP'S WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL TOLD
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE IT
WOULD HAVE BEEN A DISASTER IF
TRUMP MADE POWELL A SPECIAL
COUNSEL.
NEWLY RELEASED TRANSCRIPTS COME
AFTER IT WAS FINALLY RELEASED
AND PLACED THE BLAME SQUARELY ON
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
JOINING US NOW IS ONE OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS.
TIM, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
JOINING US.
NOW, TO THE CLEAR, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
LEGAL ISSUES.
BUT YOU REPRESENT HIM IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S
INVESTIGATIONS, INTO JANUARY
6th, AND THE MAR-A-LAGO
INVESTIGATION AS WELL.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE.
THE COMMITTEE HAS HAD A LOT TO
SAY THIS WEEK, YOUR CLIENTS HAVE
HAD A LOT TO SAY THIS WEEK.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE DEFENSE
STRATEGY GOING FORWARD.
>> SURE.
>> EARLIER THIS WEEK, THE
BEGINNING OF THE WEEK, THE
COMMITTEE REFERRED YOUR CLIENT
TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ON
FOUR DIFFERENT CRIMINAL CHARGES.
OBSTRUCTION OF AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING, CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE UNITED STATES,
CONSPIRACY TO MAKE A FALSE
STATEMENT, AND INSURRECTION.
WHAT IS YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> I MEAN, THE REFERRAL ITSELF
IS PRETTY MUCH WORTHLESS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
DOESN'T HAVE TO FOLLOW IT.
THERE'S BEEN EXISTING
INVESTIGATION WE HAVE BEEN
DEALING WITH FOR QUITE SOME
TIME.
IF ANYTHING IT POLITICIZES THE
PROCESS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE ANY AFFECT RIGHT
NOW ON OUR DEFENSE.
A LOT OF THAT IS GOING TO BE
VERY HELPFUL TO US.
>> YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY CORRECT.
IT IS A LOWER BAR TO PUT FORTH
THE REFERRALS THAN FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO ULTIMATELY
CHARGE OR PROSECUTE.
WE KNOW HERE, EVEN THOUGH THESE
ARE SYMBOLIC, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS INVESTIGATING
THIS.
AND WE KNOW SPECIAL COUNSEL JACK
SMITH HAS REQUESTED ALL THE
EVIDENCE THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS
GATHERED AND WILL ALSO RECEIVE
THIS 845-PAGE REPORT WHICH
ULTIMATELY CONCLUDES THAT THE
CENTRAL CAUSE OF JANUARY 6th WAS
ONE MAN, FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP, WHO MANY OTHERS FOLLOWED.
NONE OF THE EVENTS OF JANUARY
6th WOULD HAVE HAPPENED WITHOUT
HIM.
SO WHAT IS YOUR CLIENT'S DEFENSE
TO THAT CONCLUSION?
>> WELL, I MEAN, THAT CONCLUSION
IS A LITTLE BIT SILLY TO ME
BECAUSE THIS IS A COMMITTEE THAT
BEGAN AS EVERY INVESTIGATOR
SHOULD NEVER DO.
THEY START WITH A CONCLUSION AND
THEN THEY TRY TO BUILD EVIDENCE
THAT WOULD SUPPORT THAT.
NOW, ULTIMATELY, IF THERE WASN'T
AN ELECTION THAT WAS CONTESTED,
THEN THERE WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN A
RALLY, NONE OF THIS WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED, THAT IS CORRECT.
BUT SOMEONE WHO SPECIFICALLY
TOOK STEPS TO AVOID VIOLENCE AND
SPECIFICALLY TOLD PEOPLE NOT TO
BE VIOLENT IS DISINGENUOUS AT
BEST.
SORRY.
WELL, WE LOOK AT THIS REPORT AS
REALLY THE REPORT ITSELF IS NOT
OF MUCH VALUE.
IT'S WRITTEN BY POLITICIANS FOR
POLITICAL PURPOSE.
THE ONLY THING THAT'S REALLY
TKPWOEFG VALUE HERE IS THE
UNDERLYING EVIDENCE.
WHAT CAN BE INCLUDED AND WHAT'S
BEEN EXCLUDED.
>> LET'S LOOK AT SOME OF THE
EVIDENCE THAT THEY LAID OUT IN
SUPPORT OF THEIR CONCLUSION.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T JUST FOCUS ON
JANUARY 6th.
THEY GO ALL THE WAY BACK BEFORE
ELECTION DAY.
AND THEY ARGUE THIS PLAN TO
REFUTE AND DISRUPT ELECTION
RESULTS ARGUE IT WAS
E
PREMEDITATED.
THEY POINT TO EMAILS FROM A
CONSERVATIVE WATCH DOG GROUP IN
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYING, LOOK,
JUST REFUTE THE ELECTION NO
MATTER WHAT HAPPENS.
THEY POINT TO THE PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN ON STATES.
THEY SAY THERE WERE OVER 200
CONTACTS BY THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND HIS ASSOCIATES ON STATES.
THEY POINT TO TRUMP'S MULTIPLE
CONTACTS WITH THE RNC CHAIRMAN
TO ENSURE THEY WERE DEPUTIZED TO
PUSH THIS FALSE ELECTOR CLAIM
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS IN TOUCH
WITH JOHN EASTMAN WHEN HE WAS
DRAFTING THAT MEMO AT THE CENTER
OF THE PRESSURE CAMPAIGN ON THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
SO WHAT EVIDENCE IS IT YOU WOULD
HAVE OR YOU BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE TO REFUTE
THIS ROAD MAP TO TRY TO SUPPORT
THIS CONCLUSION?
>> SURE.
EVERYTHING THAT YOU JUST
DESCRIBED, IT CAN BE SEEN IN THE
LIGHT OF TRYING TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION.
BUT IT CAN BE SEEN IN THE LIGHT
OF ATTEMPTING TO MAKE SURE THE
ELECTION RESULTS ARE CORRECT.
AND YOU HAVE TO ASSUME FOR A
SECOND HE'S BEEN TOLD THAT
THERE'S FRAUD IN THE ELECTION.
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
SHOW THERE WERE INCONSISTENCIES,
FRAUD AND IRREGULARITIES.
AND THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE
LOOKED INTO.
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
LOOK INTO THAT IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
WHETHER IT BE THE FBI OR STATES.
WOULD THERE BE PRESSURE TO GO
BACK AND INVESTIGATE TO FIGURE
OUT WHETHER THE RESULTS ARE
ACCURATE?
ABSOLUTELY.
THAT'S WHAT WE WOULD EXPECT THE
PRESIDENT TO DO IF HE WAS
PRESENTED WITH EVIDENCE THAT THE
RESULTS WERE INACCURATE.
SO THE FACT THAT THERE IS THIS
CONTACT, THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE REQUESTS TO
INVESTIGATE, THAT'S NOT
INCRIMINATING AT ALL.
IN FACT,, THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU EXPECT THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
TO DO BECAUSE HE IS
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED TO
MAKE SURE THE LAWS OF THE UNITED
STATES ARE FAITHFULLY EXECUTED.
THE GAP THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE
IS THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE THE
LOGICAL LEAP TO SAY HE KNEW THAT
THE RESULTS WERE ACCURATE AND HE
WAS TRYING TO PUSH A FALSE
NARRATIVE THEY WERE INACCURATE
AND TRYING TO GET PEOPLE TO
FALSELY FLIP THE RESULT.
AND THAT THERE IS NOT GOING TO
BE ANY EVIDENCE FOR BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
AND ULTIMATELY, WHETHER THERE
WAS FRAUD, WHETHER THAT FRAUD
WAS ENOUGH TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION IS SOMETHING THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE THROUGH AN
INVESTIGATION, WHICH IS EXACTLY
WHAT HE WAS PUSHING FOR THIS
WHOLE TIME.
>> THE COMMITTEE ARGUES THAT THE
FORMER PRESIDENT WAS NOT A,
QUOTE, PASSIVE CONSUMERS OF THE
LIES.
AND THEY ANTICIPATED THIS
DEFENSE THAT ARGUED HE WAS
LISTENING TO HIS ATTORNEYS AND
THEN THEY PRESENTED CLIPS OF
SOME OF HIS TOP ADVISERS WHO SAY
THEY TOLD HIM NO ELECTION FRAUD.
SO HOW WILL YOU REBUT THAT
EVIDENCE?
IT SOUNDS LIKE I WASN'T
NECESSARILY HE WAS TOLD THERE
WAS ELECTION FRAUD.
HE WAS ALSO BEING TOLD THERE WAS
NOT.
HE EVEN QUESTIONED SOME OF HIS
LAWYERS, FOR EXAMPLE, SIDNEY
POWELL, HOPE HICKS I BELIEVE
TESTIFIED THAT HE WOULD COVER
THE PHONE WHILE SHE WAS TALKING
AND SAID THIS SOUNDS CRAZY.
HE WAS SKEPTICAL OF SOME OF THE
ADVICE THAT HE WAS BEING GIVEN.
>> SURE.
AND THAT'S THE THING.
HE'S BEEN GIVEN ADVICE BY
MULTIPLE PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE TELLING HIM DIFFERING
STORIES.
SOME ARE TELLING HIM STORIES
THAT THEY ARE SUPPORTING WITH
ALL SORTS OF SPREADSHEETS AND
PRESENTATIONS.
AND OTHER PEOPLE, LIKE BILL
BARR, ARE SAYING THERE'S NOTHING
THERE.
WE ARE NOT EVEN GOING TO BOTHER
INVESTIGATING IT.
AND HAD BILL PWRAR SAID SAID,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I'M GOING TO SHOW
YOU SIDNEY POWELL IS COMPLETELY
FULL OF IT, I'M GOING TO SEND
OUT FBI AGENTS AND SHOW YOU THAT
THAT WOULD HAVE RESOLVED THE
ISSUE.
SOME PEOPLE ARE SAYING IT IS
TRUE.
SOME ARE SAYING IT'S NOT TRUE.
NOBODY IS DOING A COMPREHENSIVE
INVESTIGATION TO SHOW WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED, IT'S THAT FAIL
AREA AND THAT REFUSAL TO
ACTUALLY GO FORWARD AND
CONCLUSIVELY PROVE IT ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER.
THAT'S WHERE THE AMBIGUITY COMES
IN AND WHERE THE QUESTIONS COME
IN.
>> I WILL NOTE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
BILL BARR DOESN'T BELIEVE TRUMP
HAD ANY INTEREST INTO WHAT THE
ACTUAL FACTS ARE.
HAVE YOU HAD ANY INTERACTION
WITH THE SPECIAL COUNSEL?
>> DIRECTLY?
NO, NOT YET.
>> WHEN YOU LET YOUR CLIENT SIT
DOWN WITH INVESTIGATORS FOR AN
INTERVIEW IF YOU BELIEVE HE
HAS -- THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
SIDE OF THIS, THERE IS A STORY
TO TELL.
>> WELL, THAT'S SOMETHING YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT AN INDIVIDUAL
BASIS.
WE ARE CERTAINLY NOT AT THAT
POINT IN THIS INVESTIGATION
WHERE WE WOULD EVEN CONSIDER
THAT.
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING TO DO
LATER ON DOWN THE ROAD.
IT IS DEFINITELY A SITUATION, AS
WITH ALL INVESTIGATIONS, I WANT
TO SEE WHERE THEY GO.
I WANT TO BE ACTIVE AND
COMMUNICATE WITH THEM AND TRY TO
SHOW THEM THE OTHER SIDE.
NOW, DOES THAT MEAN HAVE THE
CLIENT HIMSELF SIT DOWN OR DOES
THAT MEAN HAVE THE ATTORNEYS SIT
DOWN AND SHOW OTHER EVIDENCE,
SHOW THEM OTHER DOCUMENTS
PERHAPS.
AND ALSO SHOW THEM PROBLEMS WITH
THE EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAVE
COLLECTED THUS FAR THAT IS
SOMETHING WE WOULD DO.
SOMETHING I WOULD TRY TO DO IN
ANY INVESTIGATION BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE A SITUATION LIKE THIS
IT'S FAR BETTER FOR THE
PROSECUTORS AND THE DEFENSE TO
COME TOGETHER AND TO TRY AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE GETTING IT
RIGHT INSTEAD OF , YOU KNOW,
GOING DOWN A PATH OF CHARGING
SOMETHING THAT WOULDN'T BE
SUPPORTED AND GOING THROUGH ALL
THE CIRCUS OF LITIGATING THAT.
>> ALREADY.
WE HAVE WRAPPED FIVE TIMES.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ONE MORE
QUESTION.
>> SURE.
>> ARE YOU CONFIDENT THAT YOU
WILL THE RECORDS HAVE NOW BEEN
HROERBGTED AND TURNED OVER TO
THE GOVERNMENT?
I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN KIND OF AN
ONGOING PROCESS, HANDING OVER
BOXES, SUBPOENAS, THE SEARCH.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT ON BEHALF OF
YOUR CLIENT THAT EVERYTHING HAS
BEEN LOCATED AT THIS POINT?
>> I AM.
WE WENT THROUGH ALL POSSIBLE
LOCATIONS THAT REASONABLY COULD
HAVE DOCUMENTS.
WE WENT THROUGH SEVERAL
LOCATIONS THAT REALLY WE THOUGHT
COULDN'T CONCEIVABLY HAVE THEM.
BUT THE DOJ ASKED US SO